For the single [UNKNOWN] the applicability is fairly obvious.
There must be only one such instance of the class, and
it's must be accessible to clients from a well known place.
As far as structure is concerned, there is a single class called here,
singleton class, but it can be whatever name you want to supply.
The singleton class has two particular attributes. One of which is static or
sometimes called a class attribute. That is, it's an attribute of the class and
not an instance of the class. Here it's called unique instance.
There may also be whatever data you'd like to have within that singleton
as other attributes of the class. The singleton class also has some operations,
and one of those operations is a class method.
That class method is responsible for retrieving for
the client the particular instance which is the only instance of the singleton.
There of course may also be operations within the singleton like there could be
in any other class for providing access, for example, to the other
data that's there or doing whatever operations you'd like that singleton to do.